[Music]
listen before we get started I have to
say the only reason I get to be a
Toronto the only reason Collider gets to
be a Toronto is because it's an
expensive festival to cover is because
of sponsors I want to give a huge thank
you to Nordstrom Canada for being an
awesome sponsor and putting on this
really huge they do things they're
paying me so much for this inning I mean
you have no idea that's why it's an
expensive thing to come in I don't know
how much Nordstrom brought in accounts
and they brought it I'm saying to you
that seriously it's you know making a
movie takes finance and everything takes
financing so I'm just gonna give a huge
thank you jumping into I get to talk to
you guys today I've seen a lot of your
movie and I thought you guys did such a
great job with it and it's dealing with
subject matter that is unusual that
doesn't usually get featured in movies
so I hate asking this generic question
but so many people watching this will
not have seen the movie yet how have you
been describing the films the film to
friends and family go ahead you go well
I it's a it's a film about sound and the
psyche it's a film and sound and three
acts as kind of experienced through the
ears of a character named Reuben that
that is so beautifully plays and it's it
it's the kind of experience that is very
specific like you said something that
maybe people haven't seen but also a
very universal experience of what
happens when you when your identity is
challenged and all the things you you
thought you were become suddenly
different and it's something that we all
can come across and up against at any
time really we just think everything is
secure and it really isn't I mean it's
it's basically all just a set like this
and it can change in an instant and
that's what this movies about is what
happens when so many of the things you
think you are stripped away and what are
you left with I'll jump in with you you
really have to this is a performance and
you really have to give it on this one
and it's just watching you it felt very
raw
honest talked a little bit about reading
the script for the first time and what
sort of made you say I absolutely have
to do this
well the script is one of the best
scripts I've ever read in my life and it
was just man it just winded me as soon
as I read it I was just moved to tears I
thought it was so specific but so
profoundly Universal in what is talking
about talking about self love talking
about big questions like who the hell
are you all the things you think you are
I think it's taken away from you who are
you and yet through such a specific
world and just the kind of framing for
people I play a character called Ruben
who's a drummer in in a kind of like a
noise punk band and he suddenly loses
his hearing and he then has to go on
this journey of trying to keep his life
together somehow how does he keep his
relationship together how does he keep
his identity together
how does he learn to be deaf and so it
was quite daunting from an acting point
of view you know the prospect of having
to learn to play the drums learn sign
language and the process of preparation
which was kind of full-time for eight
months was was really intense it was
really difficult and most the time I
thought you know I suck really badly and
but it was really because of Darius's
leadership Darius's generosity of spirit
really that I went on the journey you
know it's a beautiful script it's a
scary preparation process but if you
meet the director and you feel like he's
not gonna have your back through it
you're not gonna go down that road but
Darius really late made me believe in in
his vision and myself actually in a way
and I don't think I would have done the
project if it if it wasn't this guy
leading it sure I guess I'm gonna ask
you the most important question to the
interview right now there is a scene in
the trailer towards the beginning of the
film where you and Olivia are dancing
the literal trailer the literal trail
not like trailer as in a movie trip not
a movie trailer I was scared there was a
movie trailer and I hadn't approved it
right so there's an actual trailer there
they live in a trailer in the film and
so you guys dance
I'm just curious what kind of challenges
it to do a dancing scene after Oscar
Isaac and ex machina luckily I haven't
seen that movie oh I'm it's just he's
just lying every day he said Oscar Isaac
what do I do and I was like you have to
let it go man stop talking about Oscar
Isaac I was and he was like I can't stop
thinking about Oscar Isaac it every day
I didn't know how to pronounce the film
was X mashina
X macchina X matina yeah and I don't
know what that doesn't sound right right
give me a face no it's it's a very
popular gift you know what gifts are on
the internet it's a very popular he
knows what gifts are so it's a it's a
super popular gift from ex machina where
he's like it's it's a very popular
moment I'm just trying to tease you with
the dancing this didn't go the way I
planned I was hoping for something
different it's mom show us what the
dancing anyway we could see this girl
please show us now no would you amazing
if do what if right now get up and do it
then we'll do it right on I am a Jewish
kid from suburbia and I'm like oh right
so uh no we don't have any skills at
Dancing like it's zero we cannot do
sports or dance maybe we can do a little
but I think it's actually yes I wouldn't
love everyone in on the dancing because
I'm half - it's from from a very small
time he's a terrible done I'm a terrible
dancer so I don't know how that proves
anything yeah go ahead
so anyway edit begins again here I like
getting myself in trouble but one of the
things about this film is no matter what
the dancing right no right thank you one
of the things about every film is no
matter what you're making you never have
enough time you never have enough money
so you're getting ready to film this
thing what are you really nervous about
being able to pull off with the time and
money you have well this was the
opposite problem really in many ways we
had as much time as we wanted and we had
limitless amounts of money we had I mean
we would come in some days and we would
just be
what are we gonna shoot we've got this
whole week but we don't know what we're
gonna shoot and we would just invent
scenes and we think we probably have
enough scenes like 50 different ways
yeah we'd be like why don't we just try
that on a crane and why don't we try
that on a dolly yeah cuz we can wait of
course and I'm it's not for the stunt
call with the flip that was we knew it
wouldn't make it into the movie it was
it was an exercise sure yeah so it's
really difficult sometimes when you have
all that time and money you don't know
what to do with herself and and in a way
I wish that we had less time and less we
both talked a lot about how good this
might have been if we had last move we
could just fry Tostan mind yeah
completely no but but to really address
that the the I think it's one of the the
great paradoxes of art in general and
and filmmaking certainly is that with
with restrictions like you said doesn't
matter how much money you have you would
never have enough but if you if you're
comfortable it doesn't necessarily make
a film better and one of the things we
did is we shot on 35 so when it's
rolling it's not just digital sure you
know every time you're rolling it means
something and that doesn't just raise
the energy of an actor in front of the
camera but it also raises the energy of
the whole crew every when you're rolling
it's precious it's precious time just
like life we also shot chronologically
and that I think helps and you can maybe
speak to this but certainly for me it
helps you experience the actual
trajectory of the very story you're
making so that when you're in it
regardless of how many time how much
time you have or how many takes you have
it's happening it's something that
happens before something else happens
and after something else and it is
related to life and you feel it and this
story has such a linear quality that I
think that actually really affected it
as an actor I would imagine just purely
like a logical just from my side
shooting and chronological must make it
easier in terms of like having your head
in the right place at all times on set
and not having to wonder you know what I
mean like it just it doesn't make the
properties it's a it's a tremendous gift
to be able to shoot in sequence in story
order and daria's really fought very
very hard for that and yeah
we didn't have all the money in all the
time in the world but I think we were
very intentional about the the process
that we would undertake and and trying
to preserve an element of of reality
really to to the way that we shot it was
was really central to it so for example
you know we shot in story order we you
know have an incredibly diverse cast
we have many deaf actors you know for my
character who's undergoing a process of
hearing loss we had kind of I guess
what's the word kind of implants that
were molded to my ear and they gave off
a kind of white noise statics that I
couldn't even hear my own voice and we
just tried to find what we could to
anchor this story in reality as much as
we could reality doesn't happen in
endless takes you know it happened there
has to be something at stake it's
certainly my feeling that when you when
you dare the universe to to meet you
there that something can happen and you
can't do that with comfort you can't do
that by saying guess what we have 50
takes don't worry about it it never gets
there so the music even you know Olivia
whose badass
Olivia Cooke incredible rizz learned
this music and I kind of dared them to
go play it instead of instead of telling
them don't worry I got you we're okay
we're gonna do it with separate takes
and we'll mix it later and I'll make you
look awesome and I never said that right
no you said I'm gonna try everything I
can to make you not look was correct I
said I I dared them to play the music
you know I said look you're gonna have a
live audience we're gonna shoot it and
we're not gonna be able to cheat it
there's no way because you're playing
together so go play and we're shoot and
that's the way we're doing yeah and we
did we you know we yeah we played a gig
you know we we learnt I learned to play
the drums from from scratch and and we
did it and I think that's really
characteristic of the way Darrius kind
of leads which is crazy which is insane
basically yeah did you pick up I mean
talking off camera about Derek Sena
France he also dares people to do stuff
like he pushes did you did you take
anything away from your collaborations
with him oh yeah I mean Derek and I
still work together and you know we work
together for that reason because we both
love that we both come from documentary
where it turns out you can't make life
do what you want it to do and I think
what what certainly we connect on and
gets me up every day and him is just
finding some life you know finding life
finding that lightning it's really all
about that and encouraging that and so
yeah we we talk about it all the time we
have that same experience when we write
together and absolutely man he's a he's
an inspiration to me yeah for sure so
you finished the movie you get in the
editing room what's the thing that made
you so happy when you looked at the
footage and what were you nervous about
don't say my performance I performed
well one of the things was funny about
looking at footage is that I didn't let
R is look at dailies while we shot I
hated you for that he hated me for thank
you for that yeah exactly
yeah because we didn't really have time
both so we couldn't afford playback
that's not true but we using we were
shooting films and one of the great
things with film is that you it you
can't you don't have dailies right away
you know you got to get it you got to
get a process but more than that I think
I remember you asked me before we
started shooting you were like it's
really gonna help me I was like no I'm
not gonna be your enabler I think is
what I said so so but really what that
was about is that it's not about it's
not about dissecting your performance
not about dissecting your performance
every day because that puts you in a
frontal lobe space and we wanted to be
in just a feeling visceral space as far
as when we were done what did we love
what did we not love I was really
excited about what I saw right when we
were done and you know our first
four-and-a-half hour cut I think was for
really yep our first coat was four and a
half hours which you never saw and
there's so much life in that cut you
know I I think that we had a ton of life
on this on the screen I have to pause
there and just ask the question you have
a four and half hour cut that's
obviously your assembly or is that your
first director yeah yeah no no it wasn't
a first director Scott it was an
assembly right so the movies to 12 right
now I think so how long was your first
cut that you were like pretty happy with
that you're like can I release this
version or all 2:45 got it okay so you
2:45 what's the first cut or where it
was like it was bare and you know it
wasn't did you see this 2:45 so when did
you actually see it you saw it you saw
it at about 225 I think or two yeah
something like that and you were inside
baseball we're getting geared this is
great it's a great question I love that
because actually it's like yeah it must
be such a tough process it is it's
killing your children of whistling yeah
killing your babies and your darlings
because the baby sounds creepy right
they say they say all the time killing
your babies they do all the cream saying
don't you to spoil anything but what was
the last thing that you cut out before
the final cut and why like the last
deleted scene but I don't want to know
if it's gonna spoil something then don't
tell us no we had a wonderful footage of
rizz and Olivia in the trailer in the
beginning of the movie more dancing
nope we had a whole bunch of scenes in
the trailer and there was one great
scene where Ruben rize's character is
working on a piece of music and is
showing it to her and it's and you
really get into the nuance of how they
live together and how they exist with
music and what the power dynamic is in
their relationship music together and
how they make music together but also
how she has a kind of authority around
that music and you are kind of
dogmatically in it and had all this
wonderful nuance and and that had to
come that was the very last thing to
come
the movie actually and it was it was
tough and we also had a really like one
of my favorite kind of moments in the
movie where Ruben goes running after a
leafblower
guy in the parking lot where they're
stopped because he can't stand the noise
and you kind of you kind of feel into
his a deep unrest in him and I loved it
I loved the footage but it came out at
the last moment got it
do you like you obviously have a cut the
cut that you're releasing you're
obviously super happy with do you
envision like down the road you'd ever
do like an extended cut or the stuff
that was removed is like it's gone yeah
I think it's gone got it when you think
back on the making of the film what's
like a day or two that you will always
remember the day that we played the gig
in front of a live audience you know
Olivia learn not to play the guitar she
learned how to sing and scream from this
deep place in in a way this thing isn't
a genre do and I'd learned to play the
drums and it was live audience and we
played it for real and that was
terrifying and thrilling and joyous and
you know honestly I'm not sound trying
to sound cheesy but there's so many days
on this shoot that were just so special
in such a profound way because it was
you know Darius does come from a
documentary background and when you see
us kind of there you know just living
with you know some of the people within
the deaf community there it it just kind
of felt magical you know there were just
moments where it just felt magical just
didn't ever want that shoot to finish
but I think one day in particular was
when we were playing volleyball
volleyball and then Darius and I started
wrestling and I owned him I completely
owned him and he was he was kind of
weeping I think he was crying sobbing on
the floor and the costume designer kind
of told me to get off him and and I
think that's a day of use to the young
directors out there yeah it's always let
your actors win God always let them win
I've heard that from a lot of people
real real fast cause I'm basically out
of time you crushed me crushed me as a
large man as out of my weight division
and
you definitely you definitely took it to
individual questions for each of you
later are you writing a Western with
Derek right now yeah we've been writing
that for many many years and it's an
incredibly epic and amazing story
speaking of truth and real life it's the
story of really what the searchers was
based on the story of Cynthia Ann Parker
and this man Quanah who was born from
the Comanches and really the last chief
of the Comanches it's an extraordinary
story we've been working on it forever
it's lovely and it'll get made hopefully
in the next two years I really hope that
happens I think it will happen it's just
a big one sure it's just a big it's just
in order to do it right it needs to be
really done right and we're aware of
that
we won't do it wrong and we've both been
busy and Dericks shoot shooting a
wonderful series right now with Mark
Ruffalo and and and I think it's the
next thing on the docket in some form
but it's it's a beloved script and
process we had a great time making that
two individual things real fast for you
number one when you signed on to venom
did you have any idea that that movie
was gonna do what it did
cuz holy F what do you mean by what it
did to me yeah I mean I guess I don't
really run the numbers like that before
I sign on for the movie but maybe I
should no I'm just saying like I think
it did way past what anyone ever
expected yeah I mean I guess it just
shows it's a testament to the fact that
we don't know anything right
it's crazy we don't know you don't know
the real question I want to know is I
believe is you just played this a
drummer and I believe you're playing or
have played a British Pakistani rapper
which is a massive stretch for me how'd
you come up with that idea I just never
thought I could play that role what did
you did you did it terrify you out of
your own realm British thing maybe the
Pakistani demon into both it's that kind
of truth than that I'm not sure if I
managed to but let's see it's awesome
I'm excited to a man I can't even
imagine it I believe in pushing myself
yeah I'm being sincere I'm looking
forward to seeing what you're you know
your upcoming stuff I don't know thank
you yeah yeah no I appreciate that
I mean I mean look you know it's
interesting because I was taking on this
role it's a guy that was on paper very
different to me and in the process of
playing this character I realized
actually you know how similar we are in
many ways and and that kind of made me
think well actually it's not about
necessarily seeking out characters who
are on paper really different to you
it's just about how deep you can go
inside and so for the the movie that
you're talking about which I made with
Bassam Tariq I thought actually I could
kind of find a starting point it's
really close to me and still go to a
place that's I'm uncertain about and
didn't go to a place that I haven't gone
before and so I guess I'm saying that
working on sound metal really opened me
up to a different kind of process and
and I'm really grateful to Darius for
that and to Olivia cook for that and
Loren reel off and and all the amazing
team in this that made it feel like such
a special movie sure I really want to
say that you guys did a great job and I
want to thank you so much for coming
into the suite I have a million other
questions we have more to you know what
I mean are there are other people
there's gonna be other people it's true
but again a huge thank you to Nordstrom
Canada for being an amazing sponsor I
hope everyone sees your movie I hope
it's a huge festival and preciate you so
much for coming by